what's up gangsters
i'm gonna be chilling with y'alls i'm
from seattle
um i uh i know what i look like but i'm
not that into anime
which is unfortunate because the only
women who are attracted to me are pretty
into anime
like their whole thing i'm on dates like
oh
you know i love going on dates with
anime people because i don't just have
sex
all the time sometimes i just want to
pass out holding hands too that's fun
but i am an asian right now or as i know
this country
chinese
i'm from a province in china called
south korea
women are sexy but no one thinks i'm
sexy but that doesn't make any sense
because i
think asian women are created being
[ __ ]
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to skip me if you
have sex with me our children will be
very beautiful
sometimes asian women we like exactly
the same
calm your [ __ ] i can throw on a wig and
be a seven
why are you bragging that you [ __ ] white
dudes i could poke white dudes
[Music]
uh pride can be a good thing but they're
always into like the nazis or like the
confederacy they're never into building
a castle or you'll blame
that's not white pride that's racism
don't have to be white to be racist i
can eat the juice too
but i know um i'm not racist i'm a
minority how could i be impossible
i don't even see race i only smell it
it's a little bullish in here
[Music]
but i saw a dude reading a [ __ ]
arabic which kind of freaked me out on
an airplane
uh but then i thought i'd pull the
corner of the page and put the book away
and i was like oh thank god he's got
future plans
my favorite marvel movies but black
panther uh because they gave black
children a hero they could finally look
up to
and not just someone like martha king jr
malcolm x or harriet tubman or thurgood
marshall george roger to carver
boys
now there's a fake person that dressed
like a cat
i don't know what is going to school
girl
when they're going to come out with a
yellow panda
he's slow but steady
[Music]
low furniture but yeah i love
uh dating i'm single right now i'm
looking for my soul mate
but i begin to think maybe she's a loser
she needs to get out more
[Music]
um my friends are like you need to learn
how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn to
listen to hans
[Music]
i know what you want to hear about the
uh this one lady was like did you know
that my uh i could make a baby come out
of my vagina to my vagina as a 3d
printer
i was like actually your womb is a 3d
printer your vagina is the tray
[Music]
it only brings one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print and the
whole time it's printed it's complaining
so i'm looking for a girlfriend who is
intellectually stimulated by the mental
exercise of finding me attractive
[Music]
it was in puzzles
i uh i love the ladies i think they got
the best genitals in the human race
i don't think i could ever have sex with
a dude because i've never looked at a
beautiful woman i've been like wow she's
great but is there a version of her
that's bigger and hairier and has less
kindness
i want to spend the rest of my life with
one of those
no thanks i'll stick to the beautiful
nice people
they're smooth um
i uh i i love uh
texas you know i'm a southerner too i'm
from south korea
k-pop
uh prop b recently passed so
homelessness
solved
[Music]
you know you thought the tents were
disgusting wait till they see what's
going on inside of them
oh [ __ ] let's put a tarp over it oh we
can't it's illegal puppy
i mean uh i live in a van so i can say
this [ __ ]
i love living in a van i know someone's
uh
you know judging me for it but i do it
so i can pursue comedy full-time
so if you didn't think i was funny i'm
sorry i'm trying really hard
[Music]
i'm shooting all soldiers but uh yeah i
mean i know someone is in the back like
yeah that's funny but not having your
van funny
gonna run these jokes in an apartment
apartment jokes but it's hard to date
inside of a van
because ladies and shelter it's like
this whole thing with them
even if a day goes well what usually
ends up happening is we go for a drive
until i can work up the courage until we
[Music]
arrived